c'est une rare incursion dans un monde
qu'il ne souhaite pas trop dévoiler
celui des combattants étrangers en
ukraine
le canadien jay nom fictif pour
préserver son identité nous entraîne
dans les tranchées creusées autour du
centre de formation de son équipe on
appuie à la défense territoriale
l'équivalent de la réserve
j étais arrivé en ukraine il y a une
semaine il a pris un vol de toronto à
londres il a ensuite fait le trajet
jusqu'à lviv avec des combattants
britanniques
dans ce sous-sol de kiev un instructeur
finlandais forme les civils ou combats
selon la défense ukrainienne
environ vingt mille combattants
étrangers auraient rejoint l'armée et
des milliers l'autre offrirait formation
et appui logistique
on
ne pense pas notre propre vie d'un
contexte actuel dit il
selon la défense territoriale
ukrainienne il y aurait plus de 1000
combattants canadienne dans le pays en
ce moment plus de la moitié environ 550
serait dans la grande région de la
capitale kiev
les canadiens seraient d'ailleurs si
nombreux qu'ils auraient leur propre
bataillon de la légion étrangère en
ukraine j'aimerais qu'il y en ait
davantage et surtout que le canada en
fasse plus sur le terrain même si les
risques sont grands
mais malgré tout j'ai compte offrir ses
services jusqu'à la fin de la guerre
c'est tout pour la visite je veux
retourner aider le peuple ukrainien il
sut philippe leblanc radio canada vivent
en ukraine